hey and good afternoon to everybody at
the amazing Las Vegas Comicon I want to
thank you guys for spending your
father's day with us at Comic Con here
in Las Vegas we really appreciate it
guys you know what's cool about this
event is that it's especially on Sundays
of its family day it's kids day and you
know so you see you know all the
different generations of fans out there
well the turtles have had 30 years of
growing fan base whether you are like me
and we're completely old school and
hiding my my Turtles my oversized turtle
books in my math folder or whether it's
like you came in with the cartoons
whether you came in with the toys any of
the different movies any of the
different TV shows the turtles have
impressed everybody for the last 30
years so we are lucky that we get to
connect they got the comic books with
the comic book creators the person of
the people who inspire pop culture and
that's our architect of pop culture
theme and there's nothing better than
introducing the creator of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles but before we do
that I'm going to introduce you to our
moderator coach and arrow from
collider.com the top source in pop
culture on the web you should start
following them on social media as well
but here's koi Kawai thanks for being
with us bud
how's it going guys how's Sunday we've
all survived some Vegas all right now
this man needs no introduction but you
should also know this man is signing
stuff right after this and he has an
awesome dude to talk to there's signing
stuff going on all day over there but
the man himself who invented I'd say
many of our childhoods a very specific
love of Pizza and combined many things
we love into one awesome turtle family
mr. Kevin Eastman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys are awesome thank you very much
so how many Ryder died Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle fans we got in the audience
yeah now it's just when you combine the
words Teenage Mutant Ninja and turtles
that inspires such happiness and I have
to know I want to go back to the very
beginning
why turtles well you know it really
started as a joke and that I grew up in
a very small town in Maine and my
grandmother lived in this lake
and right on the pond areas around the
lake there was just tons and tons of
turtles and I just loved them my used to
go there play them like they look like
these dinosaurs from back in the day
hanging out so I'd hang out with them
and then years later became a big fan of
Bruce Lee and I thought like if Bruce
Lee was an animal what would be the
stupidest animal he would be fast moving
martial artists slow moving turtle it
was a natural joke that made me laugh
made Peter Laird laughs and so that was
where I drew this first drawing it's on
my hat here the first drawing
Michelangelo was the first turtle ever
doodled and I said this is going to be
the next big thing ha ha ha and so
student you know Pete did a sketch
change some things I of course had to
one-up him so I did a sketch in pencil
of four turtles each of different
weapons and I had this kind of comic
book II logo that says Ninja Turtles and
then when he ain't get in he had a
Teenage Mutant to the time we looked at
it and said this is the dumbest thing
we've ever seen we've got to come up
with a story that tells how these
characters got to be the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle and that was in 1983
so dichotomy and irony became like these
things these things are at a pairing yes
where did the who's come from where did
the idea of like as that conversation
evolved into their origin which is this
rich origin tied to the comics that I
like is it is it true that daredevil
ties into the turtles yeah a little bit
okay if there's any Marvel lawyers
announce no not at all no the who's
actually evolved from it's one of those
things when you think of a most soupy or
certainly in the you know Marvel
Universe even a lot in the DC Universe
there was always this you know with Hulk
it was radioactivity with the Fantastic
Four's gamma rays through outer space
with Peter Parker it was a radioactive
so as all of these mysteries mysterious
things that sort of created these these
people to have superpowers and we love
that
so we boil it down to the simplest
simplest comic book you know scientific
logic and said well it's is and it's
some kind of got some weird mutation
stuff in it and years later we ended up
evolving the story too you know it came
from this alien race that was stranded
on planet Earth and all that kind of
stuff but the first issue is simply just
ooze with the daredevil tie-in is very
specific and that ya know but was one of
my favorite characters growing up I was
a fan of I guess more grounded
characters I liked Captain America
daredevil Batman things you know the
powers were you could see your way to
becoming those characters and so when we
were coming up with the shuttles origin
I told Peter I said you know you
remember in that scene in daredevil
where the trucks kind of barreling
through New York City in young Matt
Murdock jumps out and saves the blind
man crossing the street from getting hit
by the truck the truck slams on his
brakes this canister comes loose of the
truck hits young Matt Murdock near the
eyes and then he becomes data but they
never said what happened to the canister
and so in the turtle story it's pretty
much exactly the same but we had it
after it hits this young boy near the
eyes not Matt Murdock a completely
different kid that turn on exactly it
continued bouncing down the street and
this poor kid we need Chet lay there was
standing precariously close to a sewer
opening holding a glass terrarium with
four turtles in it canister hits the
terrarium everything goes in the sewer
the thing breaks open and lands next to
a rat that was the origin but we went
one step further in that for mark Frank
Miller's daredevil run he created this
character named stick who is Daredevils
mentor and that's where we evolved
splinter from stick splinter and Indiana
Bo's characters they had the hand we
have the foot so all these years and I
never saw a stick splinter it changes
everything oh my goodness yes so it's
but again nothing to do with daredevil
marble
so when I was watching the Netflix show
there was such a large part of me
watching the pilot and I was like yo
there's Turtles under that sewer hideout
like you guys just gave us Netflix
Turtles
totally now with the evolution of the
family I love the use of the Renaissance
painters
especially because that's the kid I
thought the Renaissance painters were
named after the Turtles
because I was just the right age to be
like these amazing artists all share
names with these Turtles I love because
childhood what was what was the impetus
to name them after beautiful painters
it's a it's a green we love that we you
know for years we love getting letters
from kids and parents and that we've
kated them on these Renaissance artists
and brought some awareness to their
artistic appreciation but it was sincere
and that okay we said we've got these
characters we started building the
origin we started creating the different
aspects of where they came from and all
that the most important thing what do
you call them because of the you know
the martial arts Asian influence we
thought maybe traditional Asian name
seen appropriate but we said you know
we're talking about a ludic a ludicrous
concept Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
gonna come up with something funnier
Doug Bob Steve still not quite there but
I was in when I was in high school I was
a huge fan of art history history and
general broad history specifically in
fact class of 1980 Westbrook go Blazers
Westbrook high in Maine I did a mural to
one of my heroes one of my artistic
heroes was leading out of da Vinci it's
still at the high school I graduated
from my tribute to Leonardo so I blurted
out to pee they said well why don't we
go really to the furthest extreme and
how about Leonardo Michelangelo and
Raphael and he just laughed and that was
our barometer so it was like this is
funny and made us laugh so we we stuck
with that and then we had probably about
a week and a half two week discussion
about Donatello because I liked it there
was a sculptor I liked named Bernini and
so I kept saying we should call the
fourth turtle Bernini and Peter was like
no no I like that name that ends and Oh
Michelangelo Donatello Leonardo so we
ended up going with Donatello so
probably it was dumb wisest choice so
and I loved that those names are so
synonymous with the characters that when
you hear like even
sometimes Leonardo DiCaprio there's a
moment I think of a turtle and then I
come back like with splinter and the
family aspect and this coming from such
a place of jest and then heart what was
the moment where you're like no no this
is a family and this is like an actual
heartwarming story of what it's like to
be ostracized when did it turn from
parody and to grounded heartfelt reality
reality well that was what was important
to us because you know you think about
so much of the Turtles really were in
sprite and inspired by the kind of comic
books that we were reading growing up I
mean we read the x-men we read Avengers
that was fantastic for those kind of
things and you would have oftentimes
these group of misfits that really
couldn't find it that was sort of
unwanted other places I'm trying to
think of a better word for it but they
sort of they be created this sort of
hodgepodge family just by being together
and supporting each other and having
this like-minded Mis about them and they
almost an adopted family and so we
thought that this really worked and
created a heart so we really wanted to
have this family dynamic there they
might be infighting they might not agree
all the time there might be lots of
issues between them but when the chips
are down and you really need to support
the ones you love they always came
together as a team to do the right thing
and be this business strong family that
was the heart and soul so you know we
felt that by issue five or six we'd
arrived at our final family group which
is the four turtle splinter Casey and
April
April was the first human introduced to
the turtles at issue two and she's kind
of a surrogate sister and then Casey's
more like a goofball brother or a goofy
cousin that they sort of allowed the
Hangout loved him just the same that was
really know for me the heart of the
turtles themselves is pizza and I just
found out moment oh so I'm a Boston guy
as strong Boston bias I love that city
so much but Papa Gino's is a very East
Coast institution what was bringing
pizza into the Turtles how did that
become where you guys like eating pizza
like these guys would love pizza was it
was a natural teenage element but I
would say that was a the job I had after
high school I worked in this small town
I grew up in
this town Westbrook Maine and I worked
at a pizza place and that's what I did
it's like so I ate a lot of pizza I
liked a lot of Pete's I still like a lot
of Pizza and so it just seemed like a
natural teenagers and then that really
you know is one of those things we
almost did it as like as somebody said
well what do they eat yeah pizza yeah it
sounded kind of as one of those jokes
and I just sort of stalk you can be a
kid forever pizza and they are yeah now
the movies in the 80s Early 90s are are
kind of the benchmark for me of like
that tone when you can capture between
action and kid film how hands-on were
you when those were getting developed
well we were very lucky in that you know
Peter and I grew up both as a huge huge
fans of artists like Jack Kirby who is
you know yes exactly
jack along with Stanley and many of the
guys created most of the Marvel Universe
Jack I think was even more intrical to
the creation of so many of those
characters and as those characters were
on to other forms of entertainment and
things like that oftentimes artists and
creators like Jack never participated in
royalties or the benefits of their
creations and so when Peter and I
created the turtles we knew how
incredibly fortunate we were that we
self-published it we own it we were the
the writers the editors the boss is the
secretaries we did every single thing
and we knew how lucky you are that we
had full control of our characters so
when Hollywood approached us and wanted
to explore the idea of you know cartoons
and toys and things like that we we said
yes but we said yes on our terms and
that we wanted full control we wanted
complete say over every script what they
look like we didn't want them to do
something stupid like but make them
would come from an alien planet filled
with Turtles right Michael Bay did you
hear that
no he's with the Marvel lawyers
somewhere he's over there with a Marvel
I know so we knew how lucky were so
Peter and I were very hands-on we we
worked with David wise and the initial 5
episodes in the first couple seasons of
turtles we worked with every we either
had a direct involvement with or
approved every single script for 300
cartoon shows all the original
live-action movies we were on set with a
incredible Jim Henson as director Steve
Barron who brought that
first movie to life which was fantastic
and it was just such a mind-blowing
experience that watching your goofy idea
you know that evolved out of one night
of two goofball wannabe artists making a
funny joke about Bruce Lee being a
turtle and then two you're sitting on a
movie set and watching these you know
like a hundred people running around in
these guys dressing these incredibly
beautifully designed rubber suits doing
martial arts and it was a completely
mind-blowing in every single aspect and
Sam Rockwell as a thug little baby Sam
Rockwell's in that movie and it's always
a delight I said I met him once and I'm
and I turn because he had unfortunately
one of the worst lines in the movie they
were trying to put some homage to Pete
and I or some acknowledgment so they
came up with this line the run of the
road is that when he was trying to tell
where the shredders warehouse he said
it's the East warehouse on Laird Minh
Island East man it was nice it's poor
Sam he actually had to say that line and
make it sound effective but no he's what
a great is it was a great character that
movies now shredder has evolved
throughout the years as well when did
you decide that the opposite of a turtle
was that character and and how do you
like that its evolution has become so
extreme has that been to watch your baby
turned into so many different things
well you know first thing you need to
look at the origin of the shredder and
some of you guys might know this if you
especially saw the turtle power movie
some of that but shredder came from
doing dishes and I mean that seriously
in that when Peter and I had our studio
which was called Mirage Studios it was a
mirage because it was our living room
and Peter's wife was an amazing cook so
she had cooked dinner often and then to
try to pay her back at some small
fashion Pete and I would wash and wash
and dry the dishes so one night Pete was
washing and I was drying and you know
those metal rectangular cheese graters
and I sort of sort of slid my hand up
inside to dry the inside and it was this
sort of held to handle there and it's
like you have these sharp little crazy
things on the thing I said man could you
imagine a bad guy with one of these on
his arm he would like like Lily he would
shred your skin off
and Peter goes that's it the shredder so
the shredder literally came from doing
dishes the opposite of pizza it all
makes sense so then you know we even you
know it even when he decide that costume
the first costume is like how do you
even walk around with that without
cutting everybody and everything around
you up you know it's a funny thing but
but but we love the shorter and it was
sort of we we kept him out of the turtle
universe for after issue one we didn't
bring him back to around issue 10 or 11
we spent a long time because we didn't
want to at the same time be one of those
comics or shows that always had the same
bad guy and everything which we ended up
being but uh but at the same time we
wanted the story to help us evolve to
the but the return of the shredder and
all this that but I love and I love that
he's still part of the that known total
universe even today now for me I gotta
ask maybe the most important question in
pop culture the Vanilla Ice rap when did
that get brought to your attention and
what was your first experience I love
the macaroni cheese commercial yeah I
see that he doesn't entice does this
great macaroni cheese commercial it's
like I think it came out last year or so
in a he's stalking macaroni cheese and
had turtle characters on it on the Shelf
in this grocery store and the mom is
with her son shopping and she notices
Vanilla Ice stacking the mac and cheese
and she stops to doing go ninja go ninja
go and his sons appalled then sort of
cover his eyes and walks away that was
great that was a really great that
exists no it's funny I was I thought the
soundtrack for the first German movie
was really wonderful they had a lot of
really great talented people on it when
they evolved it to the second movie they
wanted to do a number of things even
changing the tone of the movie in a bit
they wanted to make it more like a
live-action cartoon so they really upped
the silliness factor quite a bit and
brought in guys like Vanilla Ice to do
that song it's funny it's it's it's more
tolerable now looking back on its
specifically iconic for a little niche
now the the new films the the more CGI
heavy ones they I feel like they've
captured the character still like that
the heart of the turtles are still there
even with all the variables and I think
a testament to how solid the characters
are that even all these other things
change is there another way you want
them to go when they make the next film
as the I mean we're gonna keep having
turtles forever but the next live-action
film is there a certain direction you'd
like to see yeah I really felt that um
even when the new films I did they you
know I sold my rights on the turtles
probably twenty years ago but they still
bring me and I do a lot of work on
mainly the cartoon the comic book series
with IDW which are coming up on issue
100 which is something in saying that I
can't thank our view enough for that of
buying that series it's been eight years
of this the best ride ever working with
Tom walls and guys like that worked in a
Nickelodeon series consulted a lot with
that with Ciro Neely and I thought that
was really wonderful the 2012 series
when they came to the movies when they
knew they were gonna do a new
live-action movie they brought me in to
consult and asked like you know what do
you think about this what do you think
about that and they had kind of focused
in on one of these comics and it was
sort of one of those what-if books that
we did back in the old Mirage days this
artist Michael zuly did the turtles very
realistic they were almost six and a
half feet tall and had noses and
everything that everybody hated about
the characters in the movie that it came
out but it was an interesting take on
the characters luckily the heart and
soul was there but I just felt that I
said you know if you're relaunching
after so many years I think he should
really go back to the movie that worked
the best which was the original Jim
Henson 1990 movie it's like the turtles
were believable and and for a brief
moment in time they actually wouldn't
talk to Brian Henson Jim Hanson son they
were considering doing see you know
rubber suits with CG enhancements and
stuff like that and it just sort of you
know they sort of in Hollywood does this
sometimes and God bless Kevin Fagan what
he's done with the Marvel Universe
because you know sometimes Hollywood
goes well we know we're gonna get the
hardcore turtle fans anyway and it's
like no you know I said we want the fans
that aren't we're not you know we're
gonna get we trying to go for those fans
that we know we want to get add to the
turtle fanbase and I said well to do
that first thing you do don't piss off
my original fans these guys have loved
these characters most of their life it's
important to them and you need to do it
you know you have to you know keep that
in mind and they said okay you don't
have any say or any approval any more so
so we have six-foot-tall bulletproof
turtles that some scenes didn't work but
I will say out of those two movies I
love the fact that we finally got to see
bebop and Rocksteady on the big stream
yeah Anthony Williams was incredible and
it's so cool to hear Gary is like yeah
those are fun they did a great job
crying things like that but I feel like
if they were gonna do another movie I'd
really sort of my personal and I and
I've told them I would go back towards
you know the state maybe the two
thousand turtles that were a little
edgier we call in the 2000 series the
Fox Kids series but combine the first
turtle movie from 1990 so maybe the two
thousand so doesn't come up with
something that's more for all audiences
something that is like you know you
don't have to be bloody and edgy and
overly violent to you know tell a good
story it's like you can have
action-adventure heart soul there's so
many great things you can do so
hopefully it's something with a bit of
edge a bit of humor and a lot of heart
and soul so if it goes that way that
would be me very happy I love that we
have no matter what have a new iteration
of turtles and one of the craziest I
think is turtles and Batman and I love
that Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and
Batman are teaming up like that's a real
life sentence you guys Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles and Batman what was the
process of that like how much were you
involved well that was so much it was
such a weird thing in that um
but mentioned Jack Kirby earlier and
Jack Kirby one of them my favorite books
that Jack Kirby published wrote and
created and created wrote and and drew
was a book called command II when I
loved this book called command II
because it was it was kind of based on a
plan of the Apes kind of concept and
last boy on earth animals ruled the
ruled the university rude planet Earth
and humans were slaves and this one
smart kid command he comes up and he's
trying to change back what had happened
and so I come up with years ago this
story of like you magic Turtles mutated
Turtles going to the world of Kamandi
that's ruled by animals and so I pitched
DC this idea of doing it - Kamandi
turtles crossover and they go whoo
nobody knows who command E is why don't
you something cool like Turtles Batman
and I was like didn't think that was on
the table
we went with Batman exactly he has like
faith ever you know straight out of the
box but because I grew up as a you know
I still have drawings when I was like
eight nine ten years old of Batman and
you know and so uh luckily for us that
the amazing James Tinian came in and
came up with this concept of what he
wanted to do with the first one they
brought any incredible Freddy Williams
the artist on this series and we and I
honestly they came up with such an
incredible story and it worked so well
because it was really something that
could have failed as easily as it worked
but you guys bought it you liked it and
we've done too and actually the second
issue for the third and final crossover
is just came out two weeks ago
and it's pretty fantastic but what a joy
and what a treat has been and now
they've just released a movie which is
pretty incredible I have not seen it if
you guys seen the new Turtles Batman
movie you like it you dig it that's okay
hardcore critics right I respect the
honesty but the comic it is so much it's
really smart and it's and it's a really
solid book and I think it took a lot of
people by surprise because when you see
that medley or like okay it's a cash
grab and this wasn't it was a really
it's both characters sets of characters
being represented authentically so if
you guys haven't checked it out like
Batman is Batman and the turtles or the
Turtles yeah they can't was a really
thrilled that they kept I wasn't sure if
they would have take it more than nickel
to make it more kid-friendly not to you
know no softer but this it's got a nice
edge to it and actually there's an
artist here who's done some incredible
turtle comic books a guy named Andy Kuhn
I think he's over that section over
there but Andy was one of the guys who
designed although did all the character
designs for that movie and so you should
go see any stuff he's fantastic and you
did a great job designing the characters
for that site yeah it's not Adam West's
Batman that was my conservative Batman
66 in the turtles now in the other world
of what you're creating drawing blood
sounds fascinating and I love like the
idea that you can keep a lot of tonality
'z but also branch out so it feels like
a familiar world what was the
inspiration for drawing blood and had
that come to be drawing Bloods a new
series and for any of you guys that
helps support the Kickstarter two years
ago thank you so very much it was really
a treat and a joy to to do this it was
an idea I started
noodling on and a lot of times I'll I'll
keep these sketchbooks and I'll start
doodling around notes and ideas for
concepts and I and I always wanted to do
this kind of a spinal tap remember that
movie spinal tap sort of the heavy-metal
parody I always want to do a spinal tap
is sort of take on the comic universe
but create a guy that had created these
characters that was really fantastic he
had a lot of success but then kind of
lost it along the way and so ten years
after he had this big success he's
trying to find his path back to his
creativity and there's an element you
know I like have you seen the new show
called Barry
you know Barry I love Barry so it's kind
of like spinal tap meets Barry set in
the world of comics and character a lead
character guy named Shane Bookman
created the radically rearranged Ronin
ragdolls which of these three samurai
casts that grow up over a sushi
restaurant and they're named after
famous Japanese animators like Tomo
Miyazaki and Tezuka so those are our
fictional characters that he creates and
then so the journey sort of runs as we
run two parallels where Shane's
experiences and gangsters and thugs and
all these things we torment and do to
him in the world of all based the world
of comics and on these characters so if
you get a chance to check it out you
should he should read is it's you'll
find a lot of interesting humor and
there and it's a semi-autobiographical
but there's a lot of it that came from I
know a lot of friends over the years
Frank Miller's and Alan Moore's and
people like that I've told great stories
late night at a hotel bar after a
convention so I sort of take anecdotes
from them and sort of weave them into so
it's a fictional story we see it's a
completely fictional true story but
drawing blood check it out so if you
guys are hearing like con culture sounds
like literally a manifestation from con
culture and the I loved it like you know
heavy metal which you're obviously
heavily involved with meets samurai cats
like this is a very in a wheel house
that's like perfectly branded now before
I open this up to audience questions
because you guys are turtle diehards and
I want to give you that moment I love
that Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles has a
standard the test of time and we're now
living in a resurgence of like 80s and
early 90s culture and
in my mind stranger things is that is
the closest we've gotten to that world
coming back so I want to see a turtle
stranger things team up but if you could
have the turtles team up with anyone who
would it be well if I was going by
recommendations from fans it seems they
want a Deadpool Turtles crossover also
we get a lot of cuz people that do know
the daredevil ty and they go wouldn't be
great to do a turtle as daredevil it's
like right give a more reason to sue us
right but now it would be you know I
guess it's a tough question because
there's so many characters that I love
and enjoy the comic book universe
growing up as a fan I'm still you know
if you're one of those guys like me I
still go to the comic store every week
and I have my pull list and I still read
and I love it and enjoy it but it's like
I feel like the Batman Turtles was the
closest thing to writing the turtles
where I was a wheelhouse and the turtles
universe they really fit together
wonderfully is a story so it's like
Robert Pattinson and the Turtles coming
soon guys we're gonna make it happen all
right I'm gonna toss this box around
there's actually a microphone inside it
which is just we live in the future so
talking to the box and it actually grabs
the speakers who's got a first question
up all right of course in the middle I'm
gonna toss this cube across I did was
she just raising her hands excitedly
or yeah all right so what do you guys
help her catch it I like comics I'm not
an athlete I apologize for your head I'm
still a fan of the well you know I guess
some you know the original black and
white comic books that Peter and I did
will always be my favorite those are my
you know that was the original
inspiration that was a dream yes
actually this give it up for Peter Laird
seriously without without Peter there'd
be no Ninja Turtles those will have the
biggest place of my heart when we
evolved to the first animated cartoon it
was fun because I was really not sure if
we could make it work on that universe
is writing something for a much younger
audience for the considering the comic
books were much old in
really for a much older audience but I
guess I'd say that first turtle movie
was the perfect turtle the universe and
that it was a perfect blend of the
black-and-white comic books with the
animated series so I say definitely the
old and I didn't Utley the first turtle
movie was my favorite of all the turtle
universes so yes Oh where's the question
yeah just toss it yeah whoever whoever
catches it it's not not dangerous no I
won't hurt you much little spikes come
out if you don't ask a good question
shredder box just went to crazy right
let me to create Keith Jones great
question
Casey was a game for came about for two
reasons one that I was done in 85 and it
was around the time that we were was he
issue one two three we were heading into
issue four and we felt like two things
one it was gotten really popular in
comic books they were doing these four
issue micro series so they could do a
shorter adventure on a particular comic
book character you know Captain America
dared over whatever and we said well
that's a great idea what if we did a
for-sure miniseries but each one
featuring an individual turtle so you
could get to know their individual
personalities a little better because
you got to remember that Pete and I was
still figuring that stuff out then they
were still pretty new he hadn't
completely defined the characters so and
I had this idea that you know it just
seemed like every comic book vigilante
had like this really horrific backstory
you know there was devastation whether
his family was brutalized or people were
murdered and you know his whole city was
blown up so he took on a you know put on
a costume and when I fought crime and I
just wanted Casey to do good things but
he was influenced by watching too much
bad TV and this was inspired because I
used to tease Pete a lot at his favorite
shows where TJ Hooker remember TJ Hooker
William shot the a-team and he just
loved I pity the fool he loved these
series I'd be like dude you're killing
me
so I had KC evolve from you know he was
watching three TVs at a time so he's
always watching all this TV and that
made him decide to be a vigilante and so
being a more streetwise as a character
he had a you know hockey mask he was a
hockey player and a baseball bat when I
had him originally just a hockey mask
and a baseball bat and Pete came up with
the idea he said why don't you give him
a golf bag and you can put all kinds of
different weapons like a cricket bat a
hockey stick golf clubs and things and
so that sort of coupled with this idea
so well I wanted to have him relate to
Raphael because maybe Casey's got a few
anger management issues he needs a sort
of and so does Raphael so I figured that
if Raphael someone met somebody that was
a bit crazier than him that he might
look inward a little bit maybe sort of
and so that was the evolution of that so
Casey evolved and we fell in love with
him so much and that was an 85 when we
did that we didn't bring him back until
issue ten I wanted him back on the story
we had to write for the wait for the
right time to bring him back in and s we
wouldn't you know the shredder returned
and they attacked the second time around
shop with April and we brought Casey
back to save the day and take him out of
the thing that was like and so luckily
Casey's been part of the turtle family
ever since tonight I'm gonna interrupt
the fan questions because I remembered
one I've wondered for years all the
different turtles have different weapons
that are very specific to their
sensibilities but I didn't realize until
the video game do you guys remember the
the turtles video games I think I was
like second genesis was the one I loved
most but the way they fight is a part of
their weaponry and it allows them to
fight like a family as well when you
were designing each of them having a
different weapon was it with tactics in
mind like did you consult with martial
artists and shave it from there it was a
combination of both because it was sort
of like we felt that in part like the
weapons we also wanted to almost be part
of their personality in a little bit as
well as tactical so like you know if you
ever try to use nunchucks for example I
think it's a really silly weapon it's
like I've never not used them and not
hit myself in the head it just seems
like something how do you make this oh
it seemed really silly so that seemed
natural for Michelangelo to use a weapon
that's kind of silly really well
Raphael sort of was our Wolverine s
character so
and size are made for in clothes in
fighting with the close contact fighting
Raphael SC suited his sort of
temperament his anger management
information or management issues for
Leonardo with a katana the sword was
even you know this correlates to
thinking even with the cartoon Leonardo
had the blue Raphael had the red
Michelangelo the silly so aren't just
kind of a silly color and so with
Leonardo it's um the katana is more the
weapon of a samurai and it's more of a
royal kind of thing so blue plus the
katana was sort of a leader more of a
leader type weapon and then with
Donatello he's kind of our Czech guy and
it seems more of a pacifist like
character in purple as well as the bo
staff was more of a monk style weapon so
that was him at but the staff was also
the best when they used in the video
game because you could really punch
people from afar but you put them all
together and said tactician yeah it
works out really good they can help
fight each other and support each other
and that always tied back into the
family for me I love that like the
personality reflects everything down to
the weapon down to the cover and it's
just like if so if more team movies
could level of detail would be better
off not pointing any fingers
Avengers are doing fine but other teams
perhaps those details count if next fan
question
that was the right choice I shoulda
thrown the well you know I robbed
anybody who's asked me was was are
involved in the original Nintendo game
and if you guys remember it
we were Peter and I like probably any of
you others we didn't get through I never
got through it I tried like crazy to the
point of like anger but it's a is so we
you know our aren't Robin was just more
than what the character should look like
and there was no not really any
storyline but I remember when the game
first came out and Pete and I would go
to a comic convention like a lot of fans
would come out and they'd be very angry
with us cuz like why did you make this
game so hard it's like we didn't but
yeah I never got through the water level
it was like it was to kill me and then
you know back in those days it was um
every time you started it you had to
start at the beginning again you
couldn't save a game continued had to go
all the way back to the beginning and go
all the way first it was it was really
hard
yeah anyone under 20 in this room but
there was a time you couldn't save games
yes it was a little a starting every
time the idea that we've gone from what
you can't save a game to you can play
around the world with millions of people
in like 10 years like we don't
appreciate that enough now it was a
series of pixels that you just went here
we go
and you pretend it looked like the
characters as much as it did any other
fan question who would you want and then
you break to her after because I'm not
gonna toss this again I've learned a
valuable lesson
Jimmy I'll get sued
since you were a big Bruce Lee fan and
of course he did you know martial arts
here
did you ever train yourself or no just a
fan of martial arts I did actually it's
funny because in the early days when the
turtles are becoming popular would do
interviews and stuff and people would be
like martial arts the characters live in
New York City so you live in New York
and your black belts obviously and we
were like I think I at that time I had
not been to New York City ever yet and
my black belt training consisted of
watching every Bruce Lee movie a hundred
times and the David Carradine kung fu'
TV show and so it was even like you know
a lot of the original choreography for
figuring out some of those fights it was
just sort of guessing trying to figure
out how to make it all work and from
watching TV shows but years later I did
study and found it quite fascinating and
because you really don't understand the
culture fully till you actually start
training and I did Aikido khempo savate
Kali some Jiu Jitsu but then I did you
jujitsu because I I was always afraid
I'd hurt my my hand and he ended up
settling on savate but I tried a lot of
different ones I didn't Muay Thai and it
almost killed me that's really tough but
that was like I was probably 50 pounds
ago so so now I'm back to where I
started but now I just watched martial
arts on TV so contrary to the turtles
ninjas and pizza do not go together as
well as you think but I should get back
to the gym now I want to see Conor
McGregor vs. Leonardo know now I've got
Coley I think was a friend yeah she's
gonna hurt arm she's probably gonna
bring him in safely she got that from
martial arts she's a black belt so watch
out she was at my Friday panel when I
threw it the first time I was wondering
what are your thoughts on the new show
the new Nickelodeon show The Rise of the
Turtles it's a you know it's it's
interesting because I fell in love so
much with the 2012 series we ran from
2012 to 2017 and Sarah Neely was the
the head creative executive producer
that and Sarah was I mean look the
serial grew up in Philadelphia his dad
owned a pizza place and he was at the
age when the turtles first came out he's
like ate pizza every day drew Turtles
every day and he knew everything about
the total universe he knew him out more
about the turtle universe than I did and
so when he started the 2012 series I
thought he just did such a wonderful job
at not only bringing the heart and soul
and all the aspects and I loved ideas
like making him April more their age you
know and she had the five on a shirt so
she was officially the fifth ninja
turtle and that kind of stuff there was
so many wonderful things there was
awesome some really messed up stuff in
that series which I really like I did
the voice of ice cream Kitty
but his origin is brutal I was like
Doody you kidding me this watching this
cat transform into the like it's kind of
scary but I love ice cream Kitty but so
when when that series he brought that to
a close they really wanted to go back to
sort of the younger version of the
Turtles which was more like the original
1988 series they want to make something
lighter more colorful more I guess
geared for a younger audience again and
one of the places that had not written
really explored that much was this sort
of mystic sort of underworld which was
very much inspired by um say Big Trouble
in Little China things like that which
is one of my favorite movies so it's
it's it's having a little trouble
finding an audience right now because I
think a lot of the and Nickelodeon knows
they were taking a big risk because
there's a lot of us that you know we
love our turtles and we watch the series
and it's like even if it's a little bit
of a struggle with some of the new ones
it's hard to get into it but it's a I've
seen all the story a lot of the stories
and I think there's some really great
stuff in it but it's sort of like I like
different you know you agree yeah yeah
we got five minutes left any other
questions from you guys
the aptly dressed gentleman can we get
that to him oh we got evader first won't
get right to you yeah Peter I got a
question for you what did you think of
Donatello when he in the 2003 version of
season four when he became a monster
what what did you think of that well you
know it's it's it's an interesting thing
because when he approached these the
different episodes and the different
things you're doing to tell a dramatic
story and even like you know for example
it's like you want to try to create
something that's a bit new something
that's a bit fresh and if you sort of
become like we all become vested in our
characters and and we want them and you
sort of follow them and you never want
anything bad to happen to them or
anything to get too out of hand but at
the same time you have writers and
people that want to make things a bit
more dramatic and exciting is really to
tell a story that can be engrossing that
keeps you tuned in and wanting to see
how the the whole thing plays out so
that was an experiment like that like
even you know I refer to and the IDW
comic series we've been working on an
issue 44 we had this instance where we
have Rocksteady and Bebop
you know beat Donatello pretty severely
when this was sort of like and a great
emotional moment because we want to tie
into this aspect that Donatello created
this character called metalhead and we'd
established that you can put a human
mind inside a body like we did with
inside a brain like we did to the
fugitoid we wanted to tell this dramatic
story where while Donatello was
repairing he was inside metalhead we
thought it was like wow this is a great
story ideas kind of dramatic and stuff
but people immediately thought we killed
Donatello and we're like dude we've
never killed Donatello
so a lot of people were coming up at the
convention is a wide audience
but it was more for dramatic effect and
try to tell a good story but it was sort
of like that's one of those moments we
did it we tried it and we sort of you
know safely brought him back to where he
should be as part of the family so but
did you like it where he actually became
that big hulking monster well it's kind
of like um I liked it in that uh when
Peter and I created the character slash
and the original series that we wanted
to go this route of we have our regular
Turtles which are more of your painter
style turtles smaller turtles we wanted
to see you if you had a snapping turtle
or a large ferocious character that
would what would that be like and what
would that look like even went back to
the secret of the used movie when we had
toker and razor so it was sort of again
an inspiration and sort of a similar
parallel storyline but it was fun but
you know it's time yeah Mortal Kombat
versus Ninja Turtles hi ago that would
be are some had pork over he's ready
let's get ready to rumble I would play
and watch that yes okay I would actually
love to see Donatello try to take on
maybe scorpion or sub-zero in a second
you never know you'd be careful what you
wish for
Oh get the cube of the gentleman in the
red yeah gentleman the redhead one yeah
we got I think Chu and half minutes left
and uh and then like you mentioned early
we're gonna be back over signing from
one two three and then a short break and
then four to six so we're gonna spend
the whole afternoon with you guys so we
didn't stop by and see you guys didn't
stop by see me yesterday make sure you
come and hang out today you know thank
you thank you for bringing the turtles
and making them viable again I love them
I left the ninja aspect to them I love
the way the it inspired the next
innovation and thank you what do you
think should there be a next new Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles in the year 2020
well that's a great question you know
it's in a you know I sort of flip it
back on you guys the fans especially
because you know you think about you
know I always when I start you know an
event or I do a panel or I come and hang
out with you all the first thing I
usually do so do my slide show and this
is a great format but I always say I
have the greatest job in the universe
because I have the greatest fans in the
universe I literally could not be I am
serious I could not be up here on this
stage or sitting at that table or making
a living living my childhood fantasy my
dream of writing and drawing comics
everyday without you guys the fact that
that first black-and-white common work
in the first place is your fault thank
you thank you thank you the fact that
the cartoon series work that's also your
fault
and thank you dearly from the bottom of
my heart so everything so every version
of the turtles that's evolved it's
really you know it it's it's surprising
to me and it's a humbling and it's such
an amazing thing
that you think you know 35 years after
Pete and ISO published the first comic
book we had yeah 30 was 35 years ago
this month this past May that we through
Nickelodeon and I think we brought a new
version of the Turtles and out and it's
totally up to the kids the new fans in a
lot of the old fans whether they liked
it or not and that was what was so crazy
is that I always say that much like I
was when I was a kid you can't tell a
kid what's cool and what's not cool they
decide you decide and so the fact that
the kids found this new version of
shadows something that was appealing to
them and sort of made it almost as
successful as the original series it was
like mind blowing so if you guys want to
keep seeing Turtles and you keep
supporting me the way you have I'll do
the best I can to bring you some great
stories some great ideas and appreciate
it thank you so let's give it up for
another 35 years of Turtles the next
waves coming let's give it up for Kevin
Eastman he's gonna be signing right
after this at his boots or head on over
more questions and go see him thank you
so much man really fun no awesome thank
you very much